WM LELER: Welcome to
The Developer Show.
I'm Wm Leler, and we're here
in Los Angeles at DartConf.
And we're talking
to Leaf Peterson.
LEAF PETERSON: Thanks.
So I work on the Dart language.
I'm a developer
on the Dart team,
and I work on a
combination of things.
So I do a lot of
work on tooling.
But these days, what
I'm mostly working on
is the language
itself and thinking
about how the
language and the tools
can work together to
try and provide the best
experience possible
to our developers
and, therefore,
to our end users.
WM LELER: So what
I'm hearing here
is that Dart hits the sweet
spot between dynamic and static
languages.
Can you tell us about that?
LEAF PETERSON: Sure,
I do think that's
a strength of Dart is that
the type system in Dart
incorporates both the
notion of dynamic typing
and a very nice strong
static type system.
So you can use code
in a very dynamic way
and do a sort of duck
typing-like code.
You can call arbitrary methods
on dynamically typed things,
and it will just try
to do what it can.
Or you can write your code in
a very tightly statically typed
way and get very strong
error checking, and very good
refactoring, and
good help from all
of the IDEs and the tooling.
WM LELER: So what about
development cycles?
How will developers
be using Dart?
LEAF PETERSON: Yeah.
So one of the nice things
about Dart, I think,
is that it provides some
of the best of both worlds
of languages, like JavaScript
and Java, that are JIT compiled
and so provides you a very
sort of fast turnaround
with languages that
are ahead of time
compiled that give
you very fast startup
and fast native performance.
So Dart supports both of
those modes on both the web
and on native.
So we have a fast
developer cycle
in both places where you
get very fast turnaround.
You make a change to
your code and, boom,
things are right back up.
But then when it
comes time to ship,
you get a really aggressive
compiler that goes off and does
a lot of chewing on your code
and spits out something--
starts up really fast and
then executes very quickly.
WM LELER: So can you
talk a little bit
about the future of Dart?
LEAF PETERSON: Yeah.
So there's a lot of things that
we want to push on in Dart.
We want to keep
making it faster.
We want to make startup faster.
We want to make
execution faster,
while keeping all of these dev
cycle benefits that we have.
But we also want to add
things to the language that
make developers more
productive, and in particular,
developers more
productive writing
the kind of client-side
UI code that we
see them writing all the time.
So we're very interested
in looking at ways
to reduce the
overhead of the syntax
when you're doing something like
writing a Flutter application
or an Angular application.
WM LELER: Thank you, Leaf.
This has been fascinating.
And thank you for watching.